dann sehen wir michael roth der
staatsminister im auswärtigen amt der
hier als erster das wort ergreift den
tag frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
heute blickt europa auf uns auf den
deutschen bundestag
es geht darum ob wir der erwartung
vieler zu entsprechend vermögen dass wir
durch diese schwere krise nur gemeinsam
und solidarisch kommen hinter diesem
etwas technisch klingenden begriff
eigenmittel system der eu verbirgt sich
nämlich sehr sehr viel
es gibt die einen zu denen ich gehöre
die das für einen notwendigen und
überfälligen schritt in richtung
fiskalunion europäische union sehen
es gibt die anderen für die es das ein
notwendiges übel als teil eines
schmerzhaften paketes dass wir in der
europäischen union während unserer
ratspräsidenten präsidentschaft
geschmiedet haben um die europäische
union handlungsfähig zu halten aber eben
auch ein klares signal zu setzen dass
wir niemanden alleine lassen
es liegt im deutschen interesse dass die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit bekämpft wird
es liegt im deutschen interesse dass wir
die massiven sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen verwerfungen die mit
der pandemie verbunden sind eingehegt
werden arbeitslose griechinnen und
griechen sind auch eine gefährdung für
arbeitsplätze in deutschland
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
schnell und rasch entscheiden
inzwischen haben 14 mitgliedsstaaten der
europäischen union das
ratifizierungsverfahren abgeschlossen
jetzt sind wir dran wir alle wissen
dass die zahlen in der europäischen
union nicht gut aussehen von der
jugendarbeitslosigkeit die dramatisch
angestiegen ist habe ich bereits
gesprochen
wir alle wissen nicht wo das noch endet
aber eines muss klar sein dass wir
spätestens im sommer mit den ersten
mitteln dazu beitragen dass niemand
unter die räder kommt ich höre sehr oft
es geht ja um ein wiederaufbauprogramm
es ist mitnichten ein
wiederaufbauprogramm mit den 750
milliarden euro wollen wir dazu
beitragen dass europa sich erneuert wir
wollen den digitalisierung wir wollen in
den sozialen zusammenhalt der wollen vor
allem aber auch in mehr klimaschutz
investieren damit niemand angst haben
muss vor arbeitsplatzverlusten
es ist ein erneuerungsprozess der
schmerzhaft ist der auf vielen etwas
abverlangt aber es ist lohnenswert
und dazu gehört auch dass wir neue wege
gehen mit dem eigenmittel system das die
europäische union über eigene steuern
verfügt ich halte das im übrigen für
notwendig ich habe probleme mit einem
europäischen parlament das nur ausgaben
verantwortung trägt aber nicht auch
verantwortung trägt für die einnahmen
wir alle müssen uns dafür rechtfertigen
ob wir steuern und abgaben erhöhen oder
eben auch steuern und abgaben absenken
und ich finde dass es nur legitim
wir wissen aber auch dass diese
entscheidung einer besonderen situation
rechnung trägt denn diese pandemie ist
eine globale bewährungsprobe
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir das was
olaf scholz verantwortet hat die
bundesregierung verantwortet hat für
deutschland nämlich niemanden allein im
regen stehen zu lassen eben auch eine
europäische dimension erhält und darüber
entscheiden sie heute es geht um
solidarität im wohlverstandenen
nationalen interesse es geht um
gemeinsamkeit und es geht darum dass
dieses europa stärker solidarischer und
plumps fähiger aus dieser schweren krise
hervorgeht und ich bitte sie herzlich um
ihre unterstützung
das münster wird war dass die eu muss
schulden für das zweite hilfspaket des
next generation paket aufnehmen
ob die eu kommission diesen schritt
gehen da fängt aber von den eu-staaten
ab normalerweise muss der haushalt
ausgeglichen sein daher dieses neues
konstrukt der schuldenaufnahme und da
wittern nicht wenige vor allen dingen
auf konservativer seite dass das dann
dazu führt dass künftig die südstaaten
von den reicheren nordstaaten
durchgefüttert werden weil sie ihre
schlechten haushalte mit diesem geld
aufpäppeln dabei ist die finanzierung
dieser gelder die dann fließen genau
festgelegt für welche zwecke peter
büring jetzt von der auf dem er markiert
den letzten schritt in die illegale eu
fiskalunion was alle gegenteiligen
versprechen seit den 1990 er jahren
riecht es gab und gibt keine
rechtsgrundlage für diese eu
verschuldung auch noch dazu in extremer
höhe die der eu der eu gekommen dazu
lambsdorff sie sollten lesen der eu ist
gemäss ihren verträgen eine
kreditfinanzierung der ausgaben
grundsätzlich verboten
eine weitere geschäftsgrundlage des euro
war seit maastricht 92 niemals eine
haftungsgemeinschaft
nun bekommen wir diese sogar fast
unbegrenzt bei einer schuldenaufnahme in
höhe von jährlich gerechnet 800
milliarden euro mit tilgung bis 2058 ist
die behauptung ist doch begrenzt ein
schlechter witz und ein dammbruch
wenn dieser dann einmal gebrochen ist
dann wird brüssel immer wieder riesige
begrenzte einzelsummen zu lasten
deutscher qualität aufnehmen und sie
großzügig umverteilen
die no bail out regel des artikel 125
hat verfassungsrang
doch sie wird ignoriert die europäische
verfassung wird in eine illegale
schulden transferunion umgebaut
next generation
müsste man mit eu schulden für die
nächsten generationen übersetzen
dabei sagte das verfassungsgericht schon
2012 sinngemäß der bundestag darf keinen
mechanismen zustimmen die auf eine
haftungsübernahme für die willens
entscheidungen anderer staaten
hinauslaufen
der minister scholz und auch herr roth
eben tut dies mit dem entwaffnend
lapidaren doch verfassungsrechtlich hoch
bedenklich einsatz ab es ist der weg in
die fiskalunion und es ist ein guter weg
legal illegal völlig egal die recht
vergessenen 68er straßen parolen werden
heute ganz oben im ministerium in marmor
gemeißelt es ist bei 800 milliarden euro
absurd wenn die regierung ernsthaft
behauptet die haushaltshoheit künftige
deutsche bundestag ist sei durch solch
einen eigenmittel beschluss nicht
tangiert und diese hoheit ist gemäss
verfassungsgericht ein unveräußerlicher
kernbestand unserer nationalen
souveränität
es geht hier nicht um corona nicht nur
corona es geht um eine veränderung des
charakters der eu hin zu einem hoch
budgetierten start
ein großteil der wiederaufbau gelder
wird völlig andere zwecke als corona
folgen eingesetzt und das ist keinerlei
geheimnis bei der anhörung am montag
wurde von sachverständigen ganz offen
zugegeben dass man mit dem geld
praktisch alles machen kann
die zweckbindung der ausgaben 1 kor oder
erfolgen sei in keiner weise
gewährleistet was aber natürlich bei
einem notfall programm gemäß 122 am
samstag hören sie zu zwingend wäre herr
roth das programm heißt corona
aufbauprogramm
es geht nicht um digitalisierungs
highscore aufbauprogramm natürlich auf
corona bezogen und nur so dürfen diese
gelder verwendet werde das ist aber
nicht der fall von co2 und projekten bis
zur schuldentilgung italiens mit corona
geldern gab es wildeste ideen und die
bundesregierung stimmt solchen ideen
auch noch zu kein wunder denn es ist
ganz offen erkennbar dass auch
deutschland selbst die korona kredite zu
über 80 prozent nicht für corona zwecke
einsetzen will und wird man warte nicht
einmal mehr den anschein einer
zweckbindung die 800 milliarden sind
längst
überall in europa fest land in den
haushalten kontrollmechanismen
fehlanzeige
in der anhörung machte sich die grüne
sachverständige sogar lustig darüber
nationale kontrolle ginge ja gar nicht
von den geldgeschenken fließen übrigens
nur 28 milliarden an deutschland zurück
obwohl wir das vierfache davon bezahlen
und das 30-fache behaften es ist alles
absurd
der vorliegende eigenmittel beschluss
führt und sie noch einen illegalen
zustand eines eu-staats mit einem mega
budget hier wird der boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
eindeutig verlassen nur starten dürfen
schulden aufnehmen weil nur starten sie
aus künftigem steuereinkommen auch
wieder zurückzahlen können die eu ist
aber nach höchst der rechtsprechung kein
staat und sie darf gemäss lissabon
urteil ohne volksabstimmung auch keiner
werden und das ist eine volksabstimmung
über eine aufgabe der deutschen
staatlichkeit all das ist keine lappalie
sondern die preisgabe der selbst
gestaltungsfähigkeit deutschlands als
demokratischer verfassungsstaat wir
werden sofort nach verabschiedung dieses
gesetzes verfassungsklage einreichen ich
fordere den bundespräsidenten auf dieses
gesetz nicht zu unterzeichnen
herzlichen dank gitta böhringer für die
der vorsitzende des haushaltsausschusses
hat hier noch einmal die bedenken
geäußert no way out das hatte er mit
kohl damals auch den bundesbürgern
versprochen und es werden keine schulden
finanzierte schulden union aus der eu
werden
dieses hier ist ein erster schritt dahin
sagen die kritiker die eu nimmt nämlich
erstmals schulden für das zweite
hilfspaket next generation auf
deutschland zahlt gut ein viertel der
zuschüsse das sind rund 75 milliarden
rückläufer sind allerdings auch dabei 23
milliarden stehen deutschland zu
eckhardt rehberg der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der cdu/csu-fraktion
aber der staatsminister rot und als so
was als solches haben sie eben zu uns
gesprochen
strafen aus dem antrag zitieren von cdu
csu
und spd rechtsgrundlage für den eigenen
beschluss ist artikel 311 absatz 3 des
europäischen vertrages über die
arbeitsweise der europäischen union
das aufbäumen und stützt sich auf die
ausnahmeklausel für den fall
außergewöhnlich und gravierender
wirtschaftlicher schwierigkeiten in der
union gemäß artikel 122
und weiter heißt es in diesem antrag
eine dauerhafte schuldenaufnahme auf
europäischer ebene zur finanzierung
operative haushaltsausgaben der eu ist
im rahmen dieses eigenmittel beschlusses
nicht zulässig herr staatsminister roth
das was sie hier eben gemacht haben
sie haben als staatsminister für die
bundesregierung gesprochen
sie haben darauf abgehoben dass sie eine
fiskalunion wollen ich weise dies
ausdrücklich zurück der staatsminister
wenn sie hier so eine rede halten dann
kommen sie bitte aus der spd-fraktion
und nichts von der regierungsbank
nächste bemerkungen an dieser stelle ich
bin sehr froh herr staatsminister rot
das heute diesem eigenmittel beschluss
cdu csu spd grüne und fdp zu stimmen
und gerade die fdp hat sich das nicht
einfach gemacht hier zuzustimmen mit so
einer rede als mitglied der
bundesregierung stellen sie diese
zustimmung der fdp in frage
der staatsminister
viele kolleginnen und kollegen wahlkampf
können wir ab der ersten juliwoche
machen das was wir hier und heute machen
darüber befinden
über den eigenmitteln beschluss zum
siebenjährigen finanzer über 1000
milliarden
wir befinden weiter mit einem eigenen
beschluss über den wiederaufbau fahren
und ich darf sie zitieren was der
abteilungsleiter des fahrer aus dem
bundesfinanzministerium gestern
richtigerweise gesagt hat dieses
programm soll drei phasen haben erstens
bekämpfung der gesundheitskrise der
pandemie zweitens gezielte fiskalpolitik
um in die dritte phase zu kommen und das
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich nämlich
rückkehr zum stabilitätspakt der
staatsminister rot das ist sinn und
zweck dieses wiederaufbau fonds und
nicht das was sie ihm beschrieben haben
der marsch in die fiskalunion
zudem wirkte noch eins zu bedenken gegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wer in die fiskalunion will der muss
wissen dass dies änderung der
europäischen verträge bedarf
einstimmigkeit und er muss weiter wissen
wenn die europäischen verträge geändert
werden bedarf es hier eine zweidrittel
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag und die
sich stand heute nicht auch noch nicht
nach der wahren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deswegen sollte man bevor
man solche debatten initiiert sich mal
gedanken machen wie man möglicherweise
dahinten ankommen wenn man da hinten
nicht ankommt man sollte man diese
debatte überhaupt nicht führen
die kolleginnen kollegen ja im
haushaltsausschuss gestern mehrere
stunden debattiert wir haben eine
anhörung durchgeführt
ich weiß dass es auch vielen kolleginnen
und kollegen in meiner fraktion
schwerfällt zuzustimmen
der ein oder andere wird nicht zustimmen
das musst du das kann man auch
akzeptieren an dieser stelle auf der
anderen seite unterstützt und sage
ausdrücklich 1 herr kollege schneider
nach dieser rede des staatsministers rot
für die bundesregierung darf der der
hier den marsch in die fiskalunion
beschrieben hat da hat er uns keinen
gefallen getan und jetzt wissen ruft den
können sich sparen
dann schicken sie nächsten sollte
spd-abgeordneten hier und nicht als
staatsministers im auswärtigen amt bis
jens spiel müssen wir hier noch haben in
dieser koalition
die rede die er gehalten hatte der spd
parteitag habe ich werde mich als
mitglied der bundesregierung
herzlichen dank der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der union stinksauer eckhardt
rehberg kritisiert dass der
staatsminister für die regierung
gesprochen hat und die regierung hat in
der tat in form der bundeskanzlerin mit
ausnahme klar zugestimmt dass die eu ein
zweites hilfspaket schnürt und dafür
schulden aufnehmen kann ein
ausnahmeklausel weil man das nicht
fortsetzen will
von seiten der union der fdp soll es
keine fiskalunion geben sowie das damals
helmut kohl versprochen hat auch der
bundesfinanzminister oder scholz von der
spd hat schon mal angedeutet das sei der
richtige weg in die fiskalunion und das
muss dann wahrscheinlich nach der
bundestagswahl geklärt und christian
dürr für die fdp
herr scholz die sind doch hier im raum
hat herr roth gerade für die
bundesregierung gesprochen oder als
spd-mitglied er scheut ist wäre jetzt an
der stelle sich hierzu erklären für die
bundesregierungen das in aller klarheit
zu sagen liebe kollegen kollegen glauben
sie denn ernsthaft glauben sie denn
ernsthaft sind das was er rot hier
vorgetragen hätte heute zur abstimmung
stünde dass ein einziger freier demokrat
dafür seine hand heben würde das ist ja
im sinne aller klar zu sagen herr roth
das war eine schmierenkomödie diese hier
aufgeführt haben
ich will aber ich will aber auch sagen
das war ein weg dahin
das will ich auch in richtung der
kollegen kollegen der cdu csu sagen
zu anfang zu anfang hat auch die
bundesregierung eher noch eine position
vertreten die dem herd von herrn roth
sehr nahe kommt das ursprüngliche papier
von frau merkel und herr mag
der ursprüngliche vorschlag meine damen
und herren
der hätte sicherlich nicht die
zustimmung der freien demokraten
erfahren die frau bevor die niederlande
die österreicher die schweden die den
gemeinsam am ende mit den finden die
haben für drei ganz wichtige änderungen
gesorgt nämlich erstens eine deutliche
reduzierung der zuschüsse merkel und
stolz die wollten ursprünglich 500
milliarden euro ohne jede auflage
anregung staaten überweisen
zweitens strikte konditionalität
reformauflagen zur stärkung der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und durchsetzung
der rechtsstaatlichkeit auszahlung
deshalb nur bei fortschritt von diesen
dingen und drittens meine damen und
herren eine notbremse bei fehlverhalten
das hat es bisher noch nicht gegeben und
deswegen findet das auch die zustimmung
der freidemokrat meine damen und herren
und
ich gehe noch weiter glauben sie etwa
dass ist das was vom merkel
vorgeschlagen hatte herr kollege rehberg
eine mehrheit in ihrer eigenen fraktion
gegeben hätte ich ziehe auch dass im
zweifel bin dankbar sind klarstellung
geben in ihrer rede
diesmal hat nicht deutschland die rolle
der stabilitätsorientiert übernommen
sondern es waren die flügels die das
durchgesetzt haben angeführt vom
liberalen ministerpräsidenten der
niederlande mark britton meine damen und
herren wir können den flügels wirklich
dankbar sein dass das heute zur
abstimmung steht und nicht das was die
bundeskanzlerin ursprünglich wollte
liebe kolleginnen kollegen deswegen will
ich auch sagen wie viel mehr hätte
erreicht werden können wir deutschland
an der seite dieser länder gestanden
hätte das einmalige verschuldungs
instrument ist hätte vielleicht
abgewendet werden können denn natürlich
ist das der zentrale kritikpunkt an
diesem paket und deswegen will ich sagen
deutschland stand an der seite der
damaligen italienische regierung meine
damen und herren auch das gehört zur
wahrheit dazu und ich will dazu aufrufen
dass wir dieses paket als chance
begreifen denn zum ersten mal in der
geschichte sind die guten
reformvorschläge zur stärkung der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit des europäischen
semesters ein teil der auflagen meine
damen und herren das muss dann aber auch
durchgesetzt werden rationaler klar zu
sagen und das wird die aufgabe einer
kommende bundesregierung sein liebe
kolleginnen kollegen und zum schluss
präsidenten ich will dass die leute
richtung der afg sagen welche treffen
sie hier vertreten in europa ist total
klar
zum zweiten hat ja gerade eine
delegationsreise von ihnen nach moskau
wenigen hat weniger monate
stattgefundene frohnmeyer
das sagt ja die russische regierung
sogar selber stehen unter absolut und
darfst du da kontrolle als
bundestagsabgeordneter durch die
russische regierung meine damen und
herren wir wollen lieber mit anderen
die staaten über reformen sprechen als
wie sie befehle und losung aus moskau
halten herzlichen dank
[Applaus]